you know what realization i had the
other day as as you guys are talking
about movies yeah so um i haven't been
watching movies recently i've gone back
to being i've gone back to watching
anime now what i know i know i i
finished i finished my i finished my
seasonal video and i'm just like i feel
like continuing some of these shows out
of my own volition what did you watch
what did you do i just i just i just had
this realization the other day
one that yeah i actually like anime and
number two so i finished watching some
of these episodes and i'm just like
huh i don't have anyone to talk to this
about oh not again in my life
i realized that everyone in my life
around me doesn't watch anime anymore
and i'm just like am i the last
[ __ ] who still watches anime
i just watch i watch
normie
i don't watch if it's not on netflix
conor doesn't touch it listen i'll watch
it if it's off netflix yeah just
begrudgingly do it i'll be like for
[ __ ] sake because
okay
it's so weird because like when me and
sydney started our relationship we'd
like the start of our relationship was
like we'd watch like a new show or
something yeah between us like every
every you know every time we had some
free time and now i'm just like honey
you want to watch an anime and she's
like no
show me put on a shitty horror movie
that's what i want to watch let's let's
put on 90 day fiance and i'm just like
get that japanese [ __ ] out of you
ew
and i'm just like okay so i started my
youtube journey having no friends around
me who watched anime then i found too
many too many friends who watch anime
and i'm just like every time i hang out
with friends everyone around me watch
anime and then now i moved to japan
started an anime podcast um i'm dating a
girl who or i'm going to get married to
a girl who was a big weeb an anime fan
and no one for rounding [ __ ] watches
anime what the [ __ ] is going on
i've i've literally looped back to where
i started off at
those who don't learn from history
yeah it is the cycle of a weeb it is so
surreal now though i know more people
who've watched anime and who were like
heavy anime fans but are now just like
now i'm just like you know just like
more integrated into like the weeb
culture or like the wider anime culture
without actually watching anime it's so
weird you know that it's like the floor
is and it's like the meme it's like the
floor is watching anime i'm like
literally doing everything but yeah
i've been reading like books yeah
recently i feel like what you've been
reading my books books with no pictures
no drawing i won't talk about it because
i haven't finished them
i'm reading a few of them
like storybooks information like
fictional non-fiction
autobiography
non-fiction non-fiction i'll talk about
it when i'm i'm halfway through one
that's really good right now okay it's
about japan and it's really good i'll
talk about it when i'm done
sometimes something's something's like
okay but it's like literally the floor
is anime and i'm like [ __ ] jumping in
the air like
what timeline are we i don't know man
i'm reading is reading your book chris
pratt is gone
i'm not watching it
i feel like we are in the matrix right
now
you know you know all the signs you look
for to like to like see if the world
you're living is fake i feel like i i
feel like there's enough going on around
me right now but i'm just like
we're in the matrix right now okay all
right
actually i didn't tell you about this i
watched an anime on the plane back to
the uk okay i watched eight episodes and
i stopped i was very angry yeah i
watched was it 81 87 was 86.86
bro it was [ __ ] was it it was bad you
didn't like it i thought it was bad i've
heard really good things about it bro it
was like literally everyone knows
that's about it i like it what did you
like about it i mean i just like the
concept it's been so long since we've
seen like i i feel like it's the closest
we've had to like one of these
mecca shows that i watched growing up at
least where it was like two nations
going against each other and then
there was some mystery going on and you
didn't know what you did like the
mystery i was so bored by the mystery i
was like okay whatever and then the
whole time don't look at me i haven't
seen whole time the whole time they're
doing the whole thing of like
like
you know you know obviously obviously
racism is bad right i get it but when
they like spoon feed it to you like
racism bad huh huh it comes here
all right i get it right so it's like
it's like such an unnuanced take about
it that i was like okay all right we get
it i i get that yeah i'm just so like
i'm so bored by it i was like i get it
all right i i don't need you to tell me
that this is like this is the story like
this is yeah and i should feel sad
so they were like over explaining it to
me it felt like i mean it was very
it was very much put in your face i mean
the entire thing was basically based
around world war ii it was kind of like
nudging like huh huh
like it was the whole time watching it i
was like i was just so bored and i was
like and the whole mystery aspect to it
i was not enjoying it so actually should
we roughly explain what the plot of this
show is first sure so
what do you remember okay i'm very
curious it's been a month it's been two
months since i watched this and it was
on a plane i love it when connor
tries to describe banana yeah there is a
main emcee who is a everyone in this
world right is in this beautiful
homogenous society everyone is the same
has the same hair color and same you
know everyone looks like everyone's
lights it's aryan bro they're all aryan
that's literally what they're trying to
do just say that
they're literally they're all white
but it's anime areas they have green
hair instead of you know yeah
and and so they're in this world and
everything's perfect and and they keep
doing this [ __ ] stupid thing where
they're like and it was just like it was
so obvious what they were trying to do
where it was just not having i was just
like okay we get it they were like every
single day they'd be like we have zero
casualties in this wall isn't that
amazing zero casualties zero casualties
and the whole point of it is that they
have these mechs that are fighting and
they're piloted by the other people who
are who are not the perfect race right
and uh they make them fight in the max
and uh they have they have uh
and they yeah
these they have these met these mech
like captains these are the captains
that talk to the peasants god forbid
they have to talk to them right off
somebody has to talk to them
in this world and our main main
protagonist guess what she's sympathetic
to the the presence as they say i'm
calling them i don't know what i've got
what they're called
so i'm running with it now they're
called the person
now so she obviously she's sympathetic
and she starts to become friends with
them right oh turns out these these
other race of people they're there
they're just normal human beings who'd
have thought you know and it's just like
it's like all right come on man yeah
like come on it does sound pretty dumb
down so like it's like
it's like if you i don't know like a
disney movie take on it you know yeah it
was just so
it was like dr seuss like cat in the hat
level of talking about right i was just
like sarah oh we get it come on
21st century now we get more nuanced
takes about this i'll tell you like a
perfect analogy which will i think
you'll understand jerry it feels like
again a robuchi show without being
written by genorabuchi
so yeah okay explain that to me i get
one exactly like okay okay you get it
now you get it okay yeah okay now
explain that to me okay so
the guy who wrote psychopaths he wrote
madoka magicka and
psychopaths i i thought was amazing and
like a really good take
on the the whole societal aspect of that
but like this just felt like yes that's
what he means yeah it's like a show
that's
do you think it's bad would you think my
my opinions on this i mean i i think i i
think i think yeah i think yeah you
actually have the correct opinion where
it's like very spoon fed into you the
like racism is bad and that's never why
i kind of liked it i i kind of like more
i kind of more gravitated towards like
the mystery aspect of just like because
one thing one big thing you missed is
they're at war so this nation is at war
with another nation right i could figure
out that roughly what was going on yeah
yeah and and the other nation
has robots that are completely
autonomous like they they have technical
uh they have a technology that is way
more advanced and they have ai robots
that they're fighting against uh except
the nation that we're following has
human robots right right uh so
apparently the nation is like i can't
remember the exact details because i'm
not up to date but apparently the nation
has a time limit right and after this
time limit is over
then the robots are going to shut down
because there's no one actually telling
these robots to fight i don't know if
they like heard about y2k probably
yeah but but like i was i was more like
what drew me into with this was more the
mystery aspect and more like the
character dynamics between the main girl
and the and the group itself i agree but
at times the character dynamics did feel
real predictable and stale for me yeah
it was just kind of like i i wanted to
know more about the enemy and i want to
learn more about the mystery but
everything else was such a slog to sit
through yeah that i was just like is it
maybe because it's a concept that you've
already seen in anime before it could be
that it could also just be like i just
didn't feel like although the mystery
aspect was quite good all the other
aspects didn't really entice me
personally
you know and also i was on a plane so it
was the choice of like i can try and get
some sleep here or i can continue
watching the show and it was really
struggling every episode i kept going on
i kept thinking it's really good you
know it's not a good sign when you have
to choose between watching them
sleep
right like i i i was i i really wanted
to pick up the pace like it was really
like taking its [ __ ] time
and they really one thing i agree on it
they really like wanted to show that the
main character was sympathetic but like
it was obvious she was sympathetic and
they just kept doing things to show that
she was sympathetic over and over again
and i was just like i get it yeah we get
it we all know
we get it there's lots of sympathy
together
it's
it was just so frustrating watching the
show where they just had the same copy
and paste like action where she would
talk to someone they'd be like oh don't
talk to the peasants and then she'd be
like but i like them and then do should
literally have this conversation with
everyone yeah okay maybe that would
happen in real life the situation was
real but it was just so boring they had
to show it every goddamn time we get it
it's not normal though
i also think it was bad timing that this
came off uh came out after attack on
titan which is like i think a way better
yeah way to show
some of the themes that 86 was showing
that's true i think i think our attack
on titan was kind of like a master class
in that sense it's like it took aspects
of attack on titan and weirdly code geos
in some sense with the whole britannian
and all that yeah yeah yeah yeah and
didn't really land it with any of them
for me personally like i didn't feel
like it nailed it but it was a second
season so clearly it must have been one
night
the second season is like the second
half of the story so it's kind of more
like just a continuation yeah i've only
just heard good things about it so yeah
we spoke about anime okay
okay
we got more anime whatever you want yeah
[ __ ] do you think i've been watching
anime
joey watching i have a joke
i do want to
yeah do you want to watch platinum end
though i do want to why because it looks
edgy it looks fun oh it is edgy i've
read it it looks dumb and fun i've heard
this i've heard the ending of that is
like really bad though yeah yeah in
terms of like but it looks fun it looks
like it's [ __ ] like it looks like the
high rise invasion [ __ ] like it looks
like it's bad but also is that what you
look for nowadays you know i'm i'm
trying not to be picky with anime
because if i'm gonna be picky i'm gonna
be like joey i'm not gonna watch
anything yeah pretty cool because joey
joey's read all this [ __ ] yeah but i
haven't read this so i'm like i need to
just stop reading about stuff too much
and just pick something and watch it
yeah yeah but then i did that with 86
and i hated it
[Music]
that's the give-and-take but that might
happen with platinum that's yeah but but
then i feel like if i've at least done
that i can then at least if i get to
eight episodes and i stop i probably
have more to say than if i watch 12
episodes and be like yeah yeah i mean i
have more to think and i have more to
say about it and then i can go on our
anime podcast and talk about it why
don't you watch like something like i
don't know komi-san well why don't we do
why don't we do a thing where we don't
think we all enjoy
we all we like it
like connor watching komi-san i want to
hear connor talking about comey we
should do an anime review
like once a month where we all have to
watch one different anime and present it
like a book club oh that's so much
effort that is
joey's not going to do that not like can
i do like a manga review no we got to
post an anime because we're an
we're [ __ ] anime
about it i don't even think our viewers
want that from honestly
it's funny because people will like
people we have like 95 of viewers who i
swear i like i get bored when they talk
about anime yeah and there's five
viewers are like i hate there and talk
about it yeah i [ __ ] hate that they
call themselves the anime party because
i i [ __ ] joke i feel like i feel like
our viewers have become like everyone
around me which is everyone everyone
wasn't ex-animated oh yeah and now
everyone just finds themselves watching
anything but adam yeah it's it's so it's
so i i have noticed that i think the
episodes that we talk about anime i
think are perform worse than the ones we
talk about normal stuff some people
don't like it but it's weird because the
clips perform better yeah
i mean i mean it's because
i don't let the [ __ ]
it's weird that i mean it's not weird
because people want people want us i'm
sure to talk about certain shows and
certain series um because that's just
going to perform better
in a short lifespan but as a whole yeah
people just want to hear us talk [ __ ]
and uh chat about what's been happening
in their lives which uh right now has
been not so much moving